لم يمض وقت طويل بعد
الإعلان
عن حزمة أسلحة تزيد قيمتها عن مليار دولار
للحكومة الصينية لتعلن
استيائها أه أكثر من نصف
هذه الحزمة تتضمن ترقية بأكثر من 600
مليون دولار إلى نظام إنذار رادار مبكر تم طرحه
.  تعمل
هنا في تايوان منذ ما يقرب من عقد من الزمان ،
وهناك أيضًا 330 مليونًا
إضافيًا للصواريخ المضادة للسفن الحربية و 85 مليونًا
لصواريخ جو-جو وكل هذا
تقول الولايات المتحدة إنه لمساعدة الدفاع التايواني على
تعزيز دفاعاتها مع استمرار التوترات
في الارتفاع مع بكين  يأتي هذا
بعد يوم واحد فقط من إسقاط طائرة بدون طيار مجهولة الهوية
في جزيرة جينمن البعيدة في تايوان
والتي تقع على بعد
حوالي 6 أميال أو ما يقرب من 10 كيلومترات
من ساحل الصين القارية ،
تشير وزارة الشؤون الخارجية في تايوان إلى أن
هذه هي المرة السادسة خلال  عضة
الإدارة والمرة الخامسة فقط
هذا العام تمت
الموافقة على مبيعات الأسلحة وأصدروا بيانًا
قالوا فيه إنهم
يقدرون  تفي الولايات المتحدة بالتزاماتها بموجب
قانون العلاقات التايوانية وست
تأكيدات سلسلة من الاتفاقيات أه
وقعت منذ أكثر من 40 عامًا حيث
توافق الولايات المتحدة على الاعتراف ببكين
دبلوماسيًا وعدم الاعتراف بتايبي
لكنهم يوافقون على توفير
أسلحة دفاعية لهذه الديمقراطية ذاتية الحكم
التي  لديها حكومة خاصة بها
جيشها الخاص لأكثر من 70 عامًا
منذ نهاية الحرب الأهلية في الصين ، لكن كل
ذلك الوقت بكين وحكامها الشيوعيون
الذين لم يسيطروا أبدًا على هذه
الجزيرة يقولون إنهم في الواقع يتمتعون
بالسيادة على تايوان وهكذا في كل
مرة  انخرطت الولايات المتحدة وتايوان
في بيع أسلحة أو نوع من
التفاعل العسكري ،
وتقول بكين إنها انتهاك
لمبدأ الصين الواحدة وقد
وعدت في هذه الحالة الأخيرة
بإجراءات مضادة إذا
لم يتم إلغاء مبيعات الأسلحة والتفاعلات العسكرية هذه.
أن هذا
يهدد بشدة العلاقات الأمريكية الصينية ويعرض
السلام والاستقرار عبر مضيق تايوان
للخطر ب
وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية تقول إن هذه الأسلحة
ضرورية لأمن تايوان
وهم مستمرون في الدعوة إلى حل
سلمي لهذا التوترات المستقيمة
التي تصاعدت
كثيرًا في الأسابيع الأخيرة خاصة أن هذا
الآن هو شهر أو نحو ذلك منذ زيارة
تسببت رئيسة مجلس النواب الأمريكي نانسي بيلوسي في
قيام الصين بإجراء
تدريبات عسكرية غير مسبوقة تطوق هذه
الجزيرة بالطبع تدعي تايوان أن
زيارة بيلوسي كانت مجرد ذريعة
وأن خطط تلك
التدريبات العسكرية التي كادت أن تحاكي
حصارًا لتايوان تايوان تقول إنها قالت
تلك الخطط  كانت في مكانها لبعض
الوقت وكانت الصين تبحث فقط عن
سبب لجعلها تحدث وسوف ريبلي سي إن
تايبيه